online sales for Thanksgiving in black
friday reached a record high this year
retailers earned nearly eight billion
dollars online over that period now
that's up almost 18 percent over last
year we reported earlier how cyber
monday could be the largest online
shopping day in US history when an
estimated 6.6 billion dollars in sales
now that is a big jump from previous
years our partners at seanut recently
conducted their annual holiday shopping
survey to predict trends of the season
they found that 91% of people will buy
tech products for the holidays Lindsey
Turrentine is editor-in-chief of
cnet.com and joins us at the table
Lindsay good to see you good morning
seems every year we always say online
shopping is up and we're saying it again
this year but you're saying this year
it's really true it's really true this
year there was a lot more spending
online even on Black Friday than on you
know then in stores even on a day when
traditionally we all go line up at the
mall most people actually stay at home
and shopped online kicked off the
shopping season that way why do you see
the shift do you think why do you think
we're seeing it people like to stay at
home I mean you know unless you get
really excited about the event of going
to line up in a store it's easier and
also there's less pressure to make a
decision until you feel ready seeing it
I know you guys surveyed your readers
what did you find are the hot tech items
this year what's interesting is kind of
what's not hot this year tablets have
always made the top of the wish list
until this year and this year they're
second on most people's wish list and
for Millennials tablets don't even make
the top four what's the top one yeah
smart phones for everybody everybody
wants a smartphone this year they're not
gonna give smart phones but they want
them and then you know audio is big this
year audio is huge for Millennials
specifically wireless headphones are
really big and in fact we're finding
that everybody is really interested in
giving wireless headphones there are a
lot of new wireless headphones on the
market ear pods are easier to get this
year and there are a lot more with
digital assistance baked in so like Siri
and Google assistant now come baked into
a lot of wireless headphones so I woke
up this morning I said oh my gosh it is
Cyber Monday do you really get better
deals I mean do I need to craft some
time out of an already busy day to go
shopping is it a better deal you have
stuff to do
shopping band today apparently today is
the day you get a discount you can get
great discounts today but what you
should remember is that you can get dis
great discounts for the whole season so
a lot of people use today to research 95
percent of Millennials in our survey
said that they were gonna research today
and white if you will buy but they're
not gonna do all their shopping today I
this is super nerdy but start a Google
spreadsheet jot down what you want to
buy look at prices today and then keep
looking because this year if you're
buying for Christmas Christmas is on a
Monday you're gonna have that extra
weekend that extra weekend weekend right
here of last-minute stuff if you're
willing to go out in person and you
you'll know from doing a research now
what the prices should be one of the
things I found really interesting is you
say people are moving towards
subscription gifts you know not just
steaks but other things that you can
give as gifts to people why is that I
think that it's because people like to
buy experiences what is a subscription
give I don't even know what that is so
actually one of the most popular
subscription gets to give is a
subscription to Amazon Prime oh so it's
kind of meta but you're gonna make your
shopping easier by buying easy shopping
for somebody but also subscriptions to
streaming video service Netflix like
Netflix streaming music services like
Spotify take off the ads for your
friends not just the jelly of the Month
Club if you remember your Christmas
vacation no no in fact in our survey we
found that up to half worth looking at
Amazon Prime as a gift and then a big
chunk film services and movie services
well people spend more money this year
than last year in total you know our
survey they are planning to spend about
the same amount of money but there's a
good chunk of people and a good chunk of
Millennials who say that they're going
to have more disposable income this year
presumably because more of them are
employed well Lindsey I know that you
were trying to decide what to get Nora
but she likes bacon you have a bacon of
the Month Club there's I could get a
subscription to bacon yes Jeff think
about that actually be happy very happy
very Kevin's eater aren't I
time we appreciate it you can read more
about CNET's holiday shopping survey
Linc's report on cnet.com